so let's get started welcome everyone to
donald knuth a 23rd annual christmas
lecture entitled a conjecture that had
to be true it's hard to sum up who Don
Knuth is in a short introduction but
I'll definitely give it my best shot as
many of you know he's a computer
scientist mathematician and professor
emeritus at Stanford University he's a
renowned author of the art of computer
programming which covers many areas of
programming algorithms in their analysis
this book is still considered the first
and still best comprehensive treatment
of its subject and what the New York
Times is called the professions defining
treatise Don has written several several
volumes of this book among other books
as well as you know some some books to
pick up over here Don is well known for
sending a check for two dollars and 56
cents one hexadecimal dollar to anyone
who can spot an error in his work so go
for it I say he has won the first ACM
grace Murray hopper award the Turing
award the National Medal of Science the
John von Neumann medal excuse me
the Kyoto Prize among other awards very
impressive also Don is an accomplished
musician and as his website states if
you drop him a note he's always down for
a jam session
Don will also be turning 80 soon so make
sure to wish him an early happy birthday
and we'll be celebrating in style at a
birthday party in northern Sweden where
symposium is being held his multimedia
work for pipe organ that is 50 years in
the making
Fantasia Apocalyptica will also make its
worldwide premiere so very exciting a
man of many diverse talents we are so
honored to have him here again for his
annual lecture so let's give him a round
of applause
when what Stephanie it's great to see a
lot of good friends and a lot of new
friends here and it's also always fun
when I go and I have a good story to
tell so I hope to enjoy what I'm gonna
be talking about I'm gonna I'm gonna sit
now as you said I'm almost 80 years old
after all so the title the title tonight
is a conjecture that had to be true now
this is this subtitle is what why is it
so much fun to do research because this
look this is the kind of story that I'm
going to be talking about is is the
story that gets repeated over and over
again when when you're working on on on
problems especially what in mathematics
theoretical computer science where where
you actually not only make guesses but
you can also often prove them and and so
so you see something that that's really
out of the ordinary and all of a sudden
then you get more and more confirmations
of this pattern you try something else
and it's still still the pattern holes
and so you say you know it can't be
false on the other hand how are how on
earth are we can approve it and I want
to I'm gonna show you an example that it
that effect that I think was
particularly fun occurred to me this
year in April and then I'll talk about
about some other ones F afterwards okay
so they so they just I gotta learn how
to use this this thing every year but I
but I think it'll be easy so let me show
you
relevant picture let me try to zoom in
on this guy here we go okay you see this
did so so moon ron was a painter who's
very famous for making compositions
where he didn't have to worry about
curves and things like this but he just
had rectangles inside a rectangle
and so most of the time tonight I'm
going to be talking about wreck dividing
a rectangle into rectangles and this is
a problem of course that people have
been working on long before Mondrian I
mean the yoke we have we have pavements
in your bricks people laid lay down
rectangle put them together and make
other rectangle in many different ways
and and well this year I'm writing a
part of part of computer programming
that deals with a really cool data
structure called dancing links and any
January I extended dancing links to a
much larger class of problems and I was
thinking what would be a good problem to
have to use as a interesting test case
and it turned out it related to breaking
rectangles and direct angles so I
started playing with get a pro with
rectangles into rectangles and and I
love you know people think that that
mathematicians have been working for
hundreds of years and now where's
there's tens of thousands 100,000 of
mathematicians all I love spending every
day working on problems so how could you
how could you possibly still find us a
simple down-to-earth problem that hasn't
already been studied you know way to way
too much and the answer is that those
problems aren't rare at all they keep
they keep coming up several times a year
and this is this is an example where
we're even is this very basic problem of
rectangle into rectangles and all kinds
of of sort of stones not yet turned okay
so first of all I'm a an integer
oriented person so I want to convert
this into into something that I can
understand better so here I have a blow
a picture of that of of that thing but
what the colors aren't important that
just if the rectangles into rectangles
and so the first thing I want to mention
is that any decomposition of rectangles
into rectangles can be energized into a
into what I call a reduced
so so you look at all the other
coordinates of the vertical lines and
you can number them starting with zero
so this would be number zero this would
be 1 this would be 2 this would be 3
this would be 4 and this would be 5 and
then similarly for the horizontal line
so this would be 0 1 not too many of
those 2 3 ok now so once you once you've
done that then you can redraw the
picture to just show what the type of
this rectangle into rectangle thing is
so you make this into a 3 by 5 so I have
0 1 2 3 and then I have 5 here 1 2 3 4
whoops 5 ok and and so now this well the
boundaries always is always solid and
then there's also there's also this one
which is just this square and then and
this one goes 1 2 3 here is there the
one there what is wrong one too many
this is this is interesting but why did
I look which one am I missing here I
went from zero to one then I go to 1 to
2 I see
labeled the whoa ok so here we are and
but that but you know you saved me 20
minutes so that's really good ok now ok
so so anyway you see you see what
there's going to be it's going to be
distorted picture where where we have
you know this is going to be from 2 to 3
and this is going to go like all the way
to 4 isn't it that one there ok it's
going to be something like that well
actually you know just look at the book
and the answer here ok so so here it is
this is what this is what it alright now
alright so this is a reduced
representation and until the first
question you ask is yeah you know how
many reduced representations of
rectangle interact on 3 by 5 are there
and and so in fact that's what exercised
340s for how many of them are possible
of 3 by 5 okay well any guesses make it
make it make again there's no prize
1 million okay
how many think it's more than a me so
it's it's its twenty thousand hundred
sixty-five okay so now I've almost out
of all those decompositions three by
five what's the largest number of
rectangles that you're going to find get
caught among them all
what mm mm no no I'm saying this
particular one has nine three three four
five six seven eight but is there one
that would be kept they would have nine
or more than eight what's the biggest it
could be 15 yes okay great what is the
minimum number now this is actually
turns out to be a tricky question that
and I'm not going to take the time to
prove it but you can think about it
because it because there are lots of
wrong ways to get the answer and then
but there's also a very nice short way
and the answer is M plus n minus 1 so in
this case seven all right three plus
five minus one so so you know if you
have only six it's not reduced you must
have left out you know in a reduced case
you've got to have something that comes
at coordinate one something that comes
at coordinate two and so on all the
intermediate Corden's have to be there
in order to be reduced okay so so this
is the and it turns out that that if you
if you insist on reducing it then then
the smallest you can get is is M plus n
minus 1 well this isn't you know you
think you can check it when m and N
equals one because you have to have a
one by one that's all you can do and you
and okay so there's a there's this
question of of being the smallest number
and I and I decided I would call it I
will call this tight because you know
it's it's a it's a tight lower bound and
and and and for in order to have a
convenient way to refer to it I call a
tight paving so in tight M by n paving
is is a reduced construction that has n
plus and minus 1
rectangles inside of an M by n rectangle
okay now everybody knows that the that
the Internet is a wonderful it's a
wonderful resource for finding out about
any subject so I looked up tight paving
with Google and and here's what it
showed me okay so alright so in other
words I knew that nobody else had used
tight paving for mathematical discussion
but but a lot of a lot of people who are
actually in the paving business you know
have wonderful machines that will do it
tight okay all right now next let's try
to let's cut the big question I want to
ask is how many tight pavings are there
like three by five or M by n okay that
that's that's the question there you
start telling decided of course
naturally I wanted to investigate it
because my my beautiful data structure
was what was grinding out all the tight
pavings and I wanted to know if I was
getting the right number and also I had
a way to compute these numbers Oh real
real fast and so what but while we're
doing his guessing thing how many you
know I said there were twenty twenty
thousand yeah
twenty thousand hundred sixty five
reduced we do solutions but that
includes you know the tight ones and
also this one that it got to trivially
in the fifty
so so with my computer found with only
18 million references to memory it it
computed those those 20,000 but now it
turned out then that one of those cases
had fifteen twenty two of them had 14
199 had 13 and so on but then you know
what the smallest case was when there
were only seven rectangle and how many
of you think that might have been if it
goes out of the 20,000 okay as there was
107 one okay so 1071 ways to do it so
I'm not going to draw them all for you
but I'm going to explain to you how you
can actually count that and how that
leads to a conjecture that has to be
true any questions so far
okay all right now KB yeah what type
saving of a three by five is a it gives
a way to divide a three by five thing
into seven rectangles and your and you
have to have used every vertical line at
least once and every horizontal line at
least once
okay now and so but in order to make
that concept crystal clear let's look at
smaller cases
so let's first find all the type pavings
it has to be M plus n minus 1 so let's
look at all the type pavings for example
two by two okay so now I've got to use
okay so I took two plus two minus one is
three so so here's what here's one
example right are there any other so
yeah we got four of them because I can
rotate this four ways and that's it okay
so so two by two we get four solutions
okay now so let's let's try to get two
by three or in fact I'm gonna do three
by n so let me do three by two that so
I've got a nice like nice piece of paper
here to work with
they had a they had a conference in
Poland died last year and he sent me
this nice pad of paper and and I liked
it so much that I that I that I decided
at my birthday party next month I've got
to give out note paper but but actually
the note paper at my birthday party is
going to be triangle paper because I
because I have this I have a feeling
that that all kind of mathematics has
never been invented yet because people
haven't been given triangle three by two
and I know and I got to divide this into
4 into 4 rectangles and you know like
this is one of them all right and and
well I can I can flip it over and get
this one okay now let's come up with
another one it's got to be four and I've
got to use I've gotta have at least two
you know two horizontal lines and one
vertical line was so yeah yeah this is a
cute one right okay and and it's mirror
image okay so for these oh we got sine
waves coming out of here
alright this what this was what you drew
this guy here and now we now you know
four ways to put to put underneath that
right because we because we already did
a lot of two by twos so so I can take
any of those two by twos and stick them
in there okay so let's you know this way
and this way and this way okay and and
well we can flip those over can't we
you can't flip the last one because it's
all it's already it's already flipped
it's already its own flip okay so let's
input this guy here and then I and and I
can divide this like that I can do like
that
and I can divide this like that okay so
now I've got eleven okay well it turns
out that's it okay so so so I run my I
run my program and I get eleven answers
and you know often when I do it by hand
the computer you know finds another one
but ah till then I tried three by three
and three by four and three by five and
and the number of answers I got so I had
you know okay n equal so 3 by n N equals
0 1 2 3 4 5 I don't know what to say for
N equals 0 N equals 1 there's three by
one there's one way three by two is at
11 3 by 3 it's 64 and here it's 282 and
then it was 1071 ok now so I I guess 3
by 0 is is supposed to be a deposed to
divide the thing in 2 into 3 plus 0 into
2 rectangles anyway it let's say 0 for
that okay so now okay now the last 30
years or more there has been a wonderful
tool for all kinds of problems of this
form and and and it's been online for a
long time and so we have the our online
encyclopedia of integer sequences and
this is just the nicest thing since
sliced bread for mathematics because you
can compute your way into the literature
if you want to know if anybody else has
ever studied a problem all you have to
do is evaluate the first few cases of it
and then you look it up
and there and and the hit rate is is is
it
credible and all kinds of mathematicians
I discovered each other through the
online encyclopedia annual appeal please
make a donation to that keep it running
you know this is one of the this is one
of these I mean I I donate to Wikipedia
and Internet Archive event and and oh he
is which is the which is the wonderful
thing okay now so so I fed in these
numbers this was in April and you know
and so it said this is the number of
tight 3 by n pavings Wow what's this
well it turned out I submitted this
entry right I I you know but I typed it
in in April and nobody had done this
thing this yet before so I know it was
worth looking looking a little further
okay and so then it says and and there's
another sequence that that it got it is
a triangular array which which is the it
says you know for M by n rectangle for
all M&M it gives the number I submitted
that one too so so ok so here it says he
has a formula been invented to explain
these numbers and the answer is yes
there is a simple generating function a
simple closed form I will reveal it
after either the problem is rejected or
the solution is published because at
this time as I submitted this entry to
the online Cyclopaedia I also submitted
a problem for publication in the
American math monthly and and and so
then you give an example and then you
okay so so here was April 17th you know
I did I did the enumeration on Easter
day with April 16th in the April 17th I
submitted this and and the and not only
is this a great resource but the thing
is well curated I mean within within a
day I had seven people commenting on it
and and you're improving my presentation
X and checking everything up so Oh a is
is this fantastic and indeed that the
paper came out in the monthly
you know a couple months ago and here it
is tight Mboya and paving is the
decomposition etcetera etc etc one of
the 1071 possible 3x5 pavings is this
let a sub m and n denote the number of
tight m by n pavings determine a 3 n as
a function of n and show that when
you've got three or more that the limit
of a m n over m to the nth power exists
and compute the limit now actually I'll
say more about this because because I
didn't the way they publish me it sounds
as though I that I was able to solve
this problem
the fact is you know I knew it for M
equals 3 4 5 & 6 and there was this
beautiful pattern that had to be true
for M equals 7 8 and so on
but I'll talk more about that later so
so now I want to concentrate on the case
of 3 by n and you know later we talk
about 4 by n 5 and so all right now in
fact maybe we don't maybe warm up with
with 2 by n well however that's going to
take this I don't want to waste too much
time here so what so I so let me click
to me then we skip it but when you
really really working on on this of
course he eat at least if you do
anything like I do you don't jump quite
as fast as to the next step that I took
oh you first play around with a whole
bunch of things and make and make trial
and error and then you and you say oh
yeah this is what's going on and and and
so on but but but pretty soon
you come to a really thing in fact
there's one really great simplification
and that is that that the the problem is
equivalent that it turns out in all
these tight pavings there's exactly one
line in every in every row and exactly
one line in every column you don't have
a line over here and then another line
in the same row okay
and similarly vertically and furthermore
those lines don't cross each other they
can touch each other you know like
Japanese tatami mats aren't can touch
each other but they're not supposed to
be they're not supposed to come together
like four corners of the Tommy man it's
touching each other so you don't have a
line and another line crossing so in a
tight paving you never have a crossover
situation okay so now this is a tight
paving you can count it this is 5 by 15
and and there are 19 rectangles there so
that's that's the right number of
rectangles and there's one there's one
line and everything and in this in this
solution I'm going to I'm just going to
examine the horizontal line well of
course we use that always the top and
bottom are all you go the full way but
then here then here's the lot the one at
at that height here's the one at this
site here's another one and here's
another one okay so here we have the
horizontal lines and and so you know
there's going to be M minus 1 of these
intermediate horizontal lines M plus 1
line lines all together so for a 5 by
something that there are 4 of these
lines and if I look at the endpoints of
these things of course I'm not gonna use
all I'm not going to use all for 15
points in the thing instead I've got
you know here here so so if I look at
the end points I got one two three four
five six six it's called zero one two
three four five six
for the end point three four five six
and so and so I'm going to classify all
of the five by end solutions by what I
call the type of the solution and this
is going to be I'm going to redraw this
and forget about all the all the other
cases and so I'm going to redraw this so
this could be five four three two one
zero
and then but I'm going to do this 0 1 2
3 4 5 6 and so on
so I redraw this and so this goes one
the 6 this goes to 2 3 this goes up 5 to
6 and this goes to 2 4 okay and now the
vertical lines at these points are
predetermined because they can't cross
each other and so this is going to be a
sort of the narrowest example of this
type and so here is so so so this is a
type paving that has the same type where
I say two things are the same type is if
you only only look at the horizontal
lines and they're vertical and you don't
you ignore all of the ways of sticking
verticals in there now
the the key observation is that for
every type we can we can figure out we
can count how many things there are of
that type and so I'm going to exactly
I'm gonna illustrate that on a small
example so in fact that I had here these
which are all but these are all
reasonable types these are the types
what wait a minute
there are types of width so let's see
now I drew here all of the all of the
types that are possible for 3-bike by
two so why did I leave one of them out
let's see what's going on here this is
that one that one okay oh yeah
these eleven examples actually if I if I
look only at at at the horizontal lines
I have some cases like like this one
where I've never had a horizontal line
that started or stopped in the middle
and so this one would actually the type
of that one would be there because
because I say I ignore all the vertical
lines that that don't have a horse that
don't match your horizontal endpoint
okay so so now here's the thing if I
have a if I have a pattern that I can go
to well this time I'm going to show how
to make lots and lots of a five by
something from this pattern and and the
answer is well let me click let me draw
it a little bigger so I go five four
three two one zero and then here I'll go
zero one two three four five six
this is just so that I have space to the
room as I want this and this is going to
go across one two six this is going to
go to two three this is going to go
through four to five to six and this is
going to go to the floor and so I now
draw my vertical lines hope I do this
right okay here we go now so it so in
this region I can insert as many
vertical lines as I want
maybe maybe none or I can toss in
another one
in this region I can I can put a
vertical line above or below or above
but for each each time I insert
something I have a choice of putting it
up or down because I'm not allowed to
cross line so in this region I have I
can insert as many times as I want one
thing here sick so I have 1/2 the a
carry I can put 2 to the B of things in
here where a is some number of 0 under
zero or player here I have choices you
know in this region I have 4 choices in
this region for to the C ways to to put
in extra vertical lines still saying
with within the same type you know I
have 4 choices and and here I've got 3
so here's 3 to the D and here I got to 2
to the E and here I have 3 to the N and
and so I know for any choice of ABCDE F
of that at 0 or more I can make a I can
insert that and the resulting pattern is
going to be a tight paving it's also
it's also going to reduce to this guy
when I when I ignore all of the vertical
lines that don't that don't act that
don't match the endpoints of a
horizontal line and so the the number of
of tight pavings that reduce to this guy
is equal to the sum of 1 to the a times
2 to the B times floor to the c3 to the
d2 to the e3 to the F overall a plus B
plus C plus D plus E Plus F is equal to
n minus 6 5 or 6 of C 1 it
if they're all zero I get one two three
I get so if n is 6 that would be zero so
so I not everybody gets it but the point
is every the point is every type failing
has a type and the number of types is
small and and and and and and once I
know the type I can comment exactly how
many for all n how many have that type
because you know because for example
let's let me show you all the types now
for things of size 3 so we have 3 by
here here's the type that has on only
one thing long and so I can insert it in
order to be in this type I I can leave
it as is that gives me 3 by 1 or I or I
can I think I can go from that at and I
can and I can change it and I can make
it I'm sorry this is a 3-way ok so so I
have to make a 3 by 3 I can choose one
of these three guys and then I could
choose one of these two guys and so in
order to make that this it you know so
the neck so so I got 3 by 3 there's
going to be nine ways to do it
I'm three choices for here and three
toys for here but three by four there's
gonna be twenty seven ways to do it and
so on all of those all of those reduced
reduce to this type however this one if
I make a three by n pattern that reduces
to this type I have three to the a ways
to do this for some number a and 2 to
the B ways for this and for it so if I
want the total to come out to be five a
plus B has to be five so that means I
either have
I'm sorry a plus B has to be three
because I've already accounted for two
so so I either have three three here and
no here or one here and two here and so
on so that would be three cubed times 2
to the 0 or 3 squared times 2 to the 1
or 3 to the 1 times 2 squared 3 is 0 so
that tells me number of 3 by 5 that
corresponds to this parent so this is
the this is the the point and and and
what when you're counting when you're
counting sums of this kind I it it's
beautiful because because the method of
generating functions is exactly exactly
the solution for this so if I look at a
at a power series for example Z over Z
minus 3 I'm sorry ok
Z over Z over 1 minus 3 Z for example is
equal to if I expand this a power series
its Z plus 3 Z squared plus 9z scoob +
27 z forth and so on
this is this is a sum of a geometric
series and it's in a 0 for 1 minus 3 Z
now if I and so if I if I look at the
the number of 3 by n patterns that
satis number three by n patterns that
have this type it I said it was it was
it was one pattern of 4 3 by 1 3 4 2 by
2 9 4 3 by 3 and so on 6 so so the
coefficients of Z Z square and so on
tell you how many there are of this type
now what about this type look well here
we had to choose threes and then twos
and so that turns out to be exactly what
3 minus Z times Z over 1 minus 2 Z you
multiply these two power series together
and you get Z squared plus something
runner and I have a series that shows
all these numbers come in here so so ff3
is this is a Z over 1 minus 3z and the
coefficient until you get Z plus 3z
squared xx or then F 2 squared that's
that's for this pattern and and so
that's Z squared for Z cube so it turns
out that with this pattern we're going
to get 1 3 by 2 we're gonna get 4 3 by 3
we're gonna get 12 Z by 4 and so on and
and so so in other words I say that F K
is equal to Z over 1 minus K Z and and
in order to evaluate that this
particular sum this this is equal to if
I take this and I multiply it by Z to
the N I get F 1 F 2 F 4 F 3 F 2 F 3
so I have I have an actual formula in
terms of Z's you know and I look at the
coefficients in their formula and that
tells me exactly how many exactly how
many five by n things are going to
reduce to that particular type okay so
this this means I have a way to count
all the three by hands particularly cuz
there are there are these 52 patterns
and and the in the patterns of width -
there's two of them that come out to F 2
squared two of them come out to f1 f3
four of them come out to be f2 f3 and
then they're these are patterns of size
3 and music play and it was it was it it
was easy to grind out all these patterns
and and enter them I could feed that to
algebra system and it ground out the
numbers for the solution okay so in that
way I was able to I have to find the
formula now however I showed you that
this is a problem that's published in
the math monthly from October right and
it says here proposed solutions to the
problem should be submitted by February
28 2018 and so I better not tell you the
answer right that you know I can just
tell you that you know if you work a
little harder you will get the answer
but I don't want to give away the ya
know the spoiler alert here's I can't
tell you that
too much more okay but look but but
anyway I but but I can I can tell you
that my answer I tell you at least part
of the answer that you thought you can
check your own work and and and so I
tell you the leading term of the answer
which I had here okay so in fact I okay
so my answer actually I'm gonna actually
reveal more than I should put by three I
can't read this okay a three and is
equal to one-fourth times 3 to the n
plus three
[Music]
well I'll give you just a little more 5
times 2 to the N plus 4 and then plus
you know history terms okay so in other
words 8th a 3n you know according to
this it turns out then that a 3n is
going to be equal to 256 over 9 times
times 3 to the n plus terms that only
grow in order to to the end okay so okay
so this is the coefficient here 256 over
9 it is the rate of growth you know what
that times the power 3 what for all the
tight pavings is that my three rows and
column all right now so I have my
program answer and so naturally I
couldn't resist looking at a 4 so my
head I had 52 patterns for 52 types for
3 rows so I went to 4 rows and it turned
out that well there were 1464 different
types from the 4 rows for each of those
in a formula like f1 f3 f4 something
rather and and and the types that
involve f4 are the ones that are going
to have a 4 to the N in the answer and
it turned out that 576 of those types
made a small contribution to this too
a leading term for a four so a 4 n was
equal to something times 4 to the n plus
Big O 3 3 to the N well n times 3 there
but now and what's this
what was this magic coefficient well I'm
sorry
this was 256 overnight this one was 20
27 over 4 okay so okay so I got 27 over
4 and then I got 256 over 9 and that was
too simple to beat you know this is the
sum of 576 individual fractions each of
which was pretty awful but it all
canceled out at the end to be 256 over 9
okay so I didn't go to sleep that night
I went I went to a 5 in and it was 7 8 1
2 5 over 256 times 5 to the N plus plus
smaller term and this is power 5 250 it
looks pretty ok and the next one was 1 7
4 9 6 over 25 and so anyway the constant
in every case turned out to be M to the
2m minus 3 over m minus 1 factorial
squared have you got the oh you took a
picture of it on that format okay so
this was now this this was a conjecture
then it worked for M 3 4 5 & 6 and this
was actually this was the sum of more
than but this was full there were 4
million valid types and and it took it
took about 6 hours to do the case M
equals 6 to do the calculation and then
I feel it the Mathematica and get the
grind out all the coefficients and all
and there it was again checking it out
okay so clearly something's going on
here at that point I it to the math
monthly it's a demand explanation okay
all right now well so there was a happy
ending to the to the story because
Walter strum Quist
was the who was the referee of this
problem and the editor liked it so much
that he even told me the referees name
and got me in correspondence with
Wallace drunkest and and so so Walter
found to prove that this is indeed the
correct the correct answer and and well
it showed the problem to Richard Stanley
and I were guest with many other people
and and they said they hadn't any and
any ideas why they thought there might
be some connection with spanning trees
or something like this but but but
anyways from quiz was the guy who the
guy who solved it and and and so that
next year that that solution is going to
be published so so but but when I said
the conjecture had to be true you know I
couldn't imagine a world in which in
which these formulas you know would work
for anything there was there was a great
comet or mathematician in 19th century
named Thomas Paine Kirkman and and he
he's known mostly now for what's called
Kirtland schoolgirl problem but he was
but he was he was a pastor of an English
church and he in part-time mathematician
he ain't he he did all kind of
recreations and one of his papers which
which invented what later became known
as Steiner crippled systems although
kerkini was way ahead of Steiner one of
his papers a generalized the Steiner
systems to another thing and and
he has farmers in there which he which
he claims are true but but but when I
when I looked at at what his reasoning
was why it was true it was basically
that God wouldn't want it the formula to
be any more complicated than mine so
here he hadn't really proved his his
formulas but he just sort of said that
it had to be true
because it was too it was too hard to
believe that it could be false okay now
of course strong christop give a
rigorous proof this occurs all the time
in research when you when you see an
unusual a unexpected pattern then then
all of a sudden you jump to a conjecture
then you try it on it on another couple
of cases and then maybe you're confirmed
and and then and then you got okay now
the demands explanation and sometimes
then you then you could find the answer
sometimes you can't it in many cases in
my own life I had a conjecture was based
on on some numerical thing that I had
computed the most memorable was when I
was working on on analyzing factoring
algorithms and I and I was able to was
able to determine two to 20 decimal
places the the average size of the
second largest factor I think of a
random and bit number and and and the
third largest and so on and I and I
looked at this number and I said this
number looks a bit familiar and and so I
and and I saw in a book where they had
given the first five digits and --ml to
the five edges I Drive empirically and
the author of that article called the
number e to the minus gamma where gamma
is Euler's constant and so I said oh my
gosh either the minus gamma must be the
answer to my problem so I ran to this
was in the 70s and and we didn't have
any powerful symbolic systems on our
computers
now but I could login to two Maxima at
MIT and I remember I was so I was so
nervous I you know I I forgot the phone
number how to log in at MIT and so on
but finally I did and I typed in yeah I
went to my book to look up the decimal
expansion of gamma so that I could tell
max my raise e to minus this power and
and see if it agrees to 20 did decimals
with the number I just computed and and
and but then I looked at the number I
just computed then I and I and I found
out that was also in my book I had also
e to the minus gamma in my own book so I
didn't have to use Mathematica but a
maximum but but it disagreed in the 16th
decimal and so here I had here I had a
very natural mathematical problem and it
and it agreed with a very natural
mathematical expression but this up to
16 decimals and then failed and so how
could this be true and for the next week
I tried get a better but I done the
numerical integration with my own
software so I know naturally I suspect
is above but I couldn't find a single
error in it well finally it turned out
that that my my program was right but I
had used a formula for numerical
integration that's only that's only
correct if the fourth derivative of the
function you're integrating is
continuous and this particular function
work has a discontinuous fourth
derivative so so so so go the answer oh
so the discrepancy turned out in the
16th decimal place ok now another time I
was I was analyzing the the binary you
euclidean algorithm
it wasn't my analysis it it was Richard
Brennan and and he came up with an
analysis and and another ballet and in
France came up with another analysis and
they had
analysis of the binary algorithm for
getting GCD and they agreed to 11
decimals but then there was a
discrepancy
well it turned out that this was a real
discrepancy that there's a little bit of
there was a little bit of wobble going
on when
looked at the complex of function that
was involved in and it has a very small
amplitude but a DAC actually would would
show up if you did the exact calculation
there was a there was a small you know
Lord login type of periodicity in in
their average value zero that actually
affected these integral so you can't you
know just because you have a have
agreement to long plays it doesn't
doesn't mean that the conjecture has to
be true I've seen it go both ways now
just last month bit of bill gossipers
sent me a conjecture bill are you here
okay well and and in this one I think
almost it's almost certainly going to be
true and somebody who is finding the
answer next EUR and Ike and involves the
golden ratio people know what the golden
ratio is that this is the big the the
famous the famous number that's supposed
to represent the ratio the most
beautiful proportion between two things
and and and they and they call it Phi or
tower depending on how sophisticated a
mathematician you are and and so and so
so bill sent me whoops let's zoom in on
this on this number here two to the two
fifth power times the square root of
five times
the gamma function at 1/5 to the fourth
power and divide that by the gamma
one-tenth squared and gamma 3 10 squared
and it note okay now evaluate that to a
thousand decimal okay and so well the
the running time was which was a third
of a second and it comes out 1.618 oh
three three nine nine so it's is exactly
the golden ratio to a thousand decimal
okay so so this has to be true and and
and there are a bunch of forms of this
kind that have
have resisted proof for a while and but
then if somebody cracks them and then
and and we move on and get to another
class I want to end with something that
that's that's unsolved and I have a
feeling nope I'm feeling that if that on
the one hand it has to be true God
wouldn't want it to be any other way but
I also have a feeling that maybe nobody
will ever find a proof there might not
even be a a finite proof of the result
and and this this is related to one of
the most classical comet oral problems
of of all time the N Queens problem the
problem of placing Queens on a chess
board so that they don't attack each
other now consider the infinite Queens
problem so here we have I'll take the
entire first quadrant of the plane and I
and I imagine that I want to place
Queens on this us so that they don't
attack each other I'm going to let's
zoom in on the very beginning here so
well if the five by five works out
beautifully you've got but what I'm
saying is what's the the the smallest
possible solution the lexicographically
first solution to the infinite queens
problem so people also say greedy Queens
because because you put each Queen in
the as far to the left as you can
without attacking the ones there
previously so you start out there and
you put the first Queen right there then
the second Queen can't go next to it but
then you can make a nice move away and
in the third Queen there okay but now
the fourth Queen finally you can stick
it you can stick it here in the second
column and and the fifth Queen you can
get into the fourth column okay now look
now the sixth Queen these are all
everything is attacked now except up to
here and so the six screen goes there in
position nine and then position 11 and
then four
13 and 15 but then all of a sudden we
can fill position six with the with the
next Queen and so on so so we get this
pattern and this is a sequence that you
can look up in the online encyclopedia
of integer sequences and you'll see that
that it Neal Sloan who's the founder of
that website I entered this sequence
about a year and a half ago and and
noticed this incredibly remarkable
pattern and that is that that is that
these positions of the Queen lie almost
exactly on two lines there's dock that
there's the ones that are you know where
X is greater than Y and those that are X
is less than Y and and and what's the
slope of this line the golden ratio and
and what's the slope of this line went
over the golden ratio okay so now the
agreement is incredibly good and I I
wrote a program to calculate the numbers
and it's a sine line you can look it up
it's a literate program and it has a lot
of interesting little hacks in it
infinitely many queens and it it needs
only on the average something like nine
memory references per value of n and so
you can you can quickly go up to several
hundred billion in the sequence and and
when you and when you check it out you
know like suppose like when I go up to a
billion okay well then almost all of
those numbers are either one six one
eight oh three or or six one eight oh
three in the neighborhood of a billion
plus plus or minus you know one two
three four five all those numbers are
very close to are to either five times a
million or a billion or a billion over
five and and the patterns are reared
they there are a few screen points but
the outliers seem to stop at about at
about 4,000 or so and and and and
there's a very tight balance so that
seemed to be true on the other hand it
might be like Goldbach's conjecture we
might not ever find a proof of it we
just know that that it has to be true
because it's overwhelmingly probable
probably true so so that's a technique
so now to recapitulate I I showed you
the problem that I that I ran across in
April that got me hooked when I saw I
saw this strange pattern involving
powers and factorials and and I checked
it and I said oh yeah this has to be
true then I submitted it to the monthly
and another mathematician saw it he
actually found a way to prove it so
great then I gave a couple of other
examples of cases where where things did
turn out to be true that they don't and
and here's one that brand new brand new
open how many mathematicians are gonna
are gonna work on it it's quite
intriguing because you know yeah
absolutely no economic payoff whatsoever
that's completely you do it just purely
for love and beauty and so so that so
this it this is the way research goes
and and when you do find the proof then
you're really happy for a couple of days
and of course then the next day you find
another problem and and again you have
to have to solve that one okay thanks
very much for this
[Applause]
[Music]
questions I'm sorry I didn't hear
conjecture in with the camera functions
the conjecture about the demo function
yes it's two kids so there are a lot of
identities that involve the gamma
function
you know gamma x times gamma 1 minus X
and various things like this the
triplication formulas and things like
this and this seems to to be related to
the critter placation formula but but i
think i think i've used it in some new
ways and you brought up your brought in
some other stuff in here so yeah so as
far as I know he hasn't solved it yet
but what he posted this beginning about
totally the reason I read the reason I
think this was going to be solved is
because I know that there's a lot of
mathematics of this kind machinery
that's that's there but the other one
the Queen's problem it's it's look like
nobody even knows that all the integers
are going to occur somewhere in the
sequence you're there Mike there might
be some some coordinate that that's
always ruled out it Neil said he he
thought he had a proof of it but but but
when he got to writing up the paper it
all it all collapsed so it it depends on
random from sort of random phenomenon
that just oh yeah one of these queens is
probably gonna it's probably going to be
there and since we're all on these on
these lines and then but you know
they're so
there's a lot of structure to it that's
why I was able to write this tricky
program that that needs so fix a few
operations to calculate it like
attribute the brute-force program would
would be more like an Ncube time instead
of instead of linear with a very very
small coefficient the boat the program
needs it needs memory a portion of the
end but it's very cache friendly okay no
more questions thank you Merry Christmas
[Applause]
you